each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
good morning everyone it's my pleasure
to introduce Frances david francis david
is a PhD candidate from University of
Illinois at urbana-champaign you're
supposed to get your PhD in August so
he's interviewing with the security part
of the distributed system a security
group and he's going to tell us about
some of his work on how to exploit
hardware features to undermine software
security Thank You Helen it's a good
morning and like Helen said I'm going to
talk to you about how some hardware
features can actually undermine system
security and none of us can deny that
there's been a rapid growth in hardware
technology there's there's been really
progress from single core cpus to
multi-core CPUs of today there's there's
the GPUs in in computers have gone from
ten million transistors of 10 100 fold
increase in that number and there's been
work and actually even doing computation
of these gpus now there's lots of course
there's more features there's lots of
complexity and a lot of this is
configurable and all of this hell I mean
gives you tremendous opportunity there's
a lot of opportunity to build really
interesting systems but there's also a
huge opportunity here for malware since
these this complex Hardware has
significant state information there's so
much configuration settings and it's
highly configurable as lots of debug
features that are left into the hardware
and there's lots of unused functionality
as well so if you take a typical cell
phone the actual hardware in the cell
phone supports a lot of functionality
and there's many timers is there's lots
of specialized features on the phone
which most operating systems don't end
up using the operating systems tend to
be general-purpose operating system so
if you take Linux for exam
it doesn't really exploit every single
feature that's on these on these mobile
phones for example there's lots of
unused functionality there's also an
expected behavior of hardware sometimes
the hardware behaves in ways that you
don't really expect so what I'm going to
talk to you today about is two different
tools essentially the proof of concept
attacks which demonstrate that hardware
features and behavior can be actually
exploited in order to build malware and
the two projects i'm going to talk to
you about our cloaker which essentially
exploits hardware features in order to
provide a malicious rootkit environment
and the other thing is I'm going to talk
about is boot jacker which essentially
exploits memory preservation a dram
memory preservation in order to break
into a system and that essentially
brings us to the outline of today's talk
it's a long talk so I'm going to spend
most of my time on the cloaker rootkit
word and I'm going to give you a brief
overview of the boot jacker work and
before concluding and parking up with
some other topics so let's start with
cloaker and I'm not going to take
complete credit for the whole thing this
is definitely a joint work the paper
wouldn't have been possible without my
colleagues at the University Alec Jeff
and my advisor professor Campbell and
what we are looking at here is rootkits
and to put the notion of rootkits into
the correct perspective I have this
picture here that essentially shows you
a typical attack scenario so the
attacker first has to break into the
system there's essentially you
explaining some sort of design flaw or
an implementation flaw or like just root
for space word cracking or social
engineering attacks just to gain access
to the system then the next stage is
somehow maintaining control over the
system and that's where the rootkit
comes in so the attacker removes all the
faces of the break-in and installs the
rootkit and that
is going to be kind of the main focus of
today's talk on the cloaker part of it
and the rootkit essentially provides a
platform in some sense for performing
malicious activity and that's stealing
passwords financial information or
running bots for spam or just using it
as another platform to attack others and
so I'm not going to really talk about a
vulnerability in the system that an
attacker is going to use to break in I'm
assuming there's going to be some Muller
ability and I mean this is it's well
known there's lots of different
platforms today that there's always some
vulnerability the iphone was broken into
linux phones from motorola i've been
broken into so i'm not going to talk
about how to break into the phone but
i'll talk about how how to maintain
surreptitious control so in order to put
put this rootkit that we built into
perspective there's lots of other folks
who've been researching root kids and
malware and rootkits initially started
off being user mode applications so
there were these user mode binary
programs that would replace system files
on your computer alert system for
example the process the the program that
displays the process list would be
replaced by this other binary which
would hide a malicious process for
example and then root kids moved on to
being kernel mode when system defenders
essentially security researchers started
figuring out ways to to detect user mode
rootkits and and so on there's been a
stages of development and all of this
has essentially been driven by advances
in detection technology so this is
continual struggle between the good guys
and the bad guys and so that kind of
drives this evolution and let's look at
each of those stages in a little bit
more detail so the user mode rootkits
like I said essentially our
modifications to user programs and the
when such root kits were found in the
wild the detection techniques that
people came up with is where essentially
to
sure that the integrity of the system
files are is preserved and so they built
integrity checkers and there's also like
traditional antivirus signature checking
type of tools as well which check for
malware signatures in various file
system then the so once there were easy
detection techniques for for user mode
which case we the malware guys resulted
to kernel-mode rootkits where they would
insert kernel modules modify the colonel
in various ways and there are two two
distinct categorizations of the of such
kernel-mode rootkits as well so one
class of such root case modifies kernel
code and these are kind of easy to
detect again you can just same use the
same signature integrity check kind of
ideas and apply them to the kernel space
and the other type of kernel-mode
rootkits manipulates Colonel data and
these are more insidious so they would
essentially manipulate some state in the
dynamic state in the kernel and
detecting these by integrity or
signature checks is insufficient so
researchers came up with lots of anomaly
checkers which check for odd behavior in
the system so looking at the system from
two different perspectives for example a
high level view and a low level view and
seeing if they match so studying and
trying to extract some some anomalous
behavior of the system and there's
they've been pretty successful that that
modern anomaly detect detection
techniques essentially they've been
they've shown that they can detect a lot
of these existing kernel-mode rootkits
that are out there so the next step
firmware root kids were proposed a
couple of years ago and essentially they
work in the same way as kernel-mode
rootkits well normal operation the
former aspect of it is just for
persistence so that they can remain in
the system through a power down up to a
power cycle operation and the this is
essentially done by white hat researcher
they essentially showed that you could
have such rootkits the deciding the the
bias of the system the acpi of the pci
by us and so on and then Sam King
finding pioneered the work on
virtualization based rootkits here at
Microsoft Research in fact and the idea
there is run the rootkit the malware at
a layer lower than everything else
that's running in the system so you move
the whole rootkit to the virtual machine
monitor and run the rest of the system
as a virtual machine and people have
argued that may be such root kids aren't
that big of a deal because I mean there
are techniques that one can employ just
to check for the fact whether you're
whether or not you're running in a
virtualized environment and that would
hopefully kind of indicate that there's
something wrong in the system so maybe
detection for virtual machine-based
rootkits is just reduces to the problem
of detecting if you are running in a
virtualization virtualized environment
and like I said sub where it was one of
those root case blue pill is another
root K that uses into I mean AMD's
hardware virtualization support and to
be fair only these first two types of
rootkits have been seen in the wild
today keeps popping up but the firmware
rootkits are Wow do not show this
message again oh no okay maybe you can
just turn it off okay so to be fair only
those first two types of root kids have
been seen in the wild today and firmware
rootkits virtual machine-based root kids
and what I'm going to talk about are all
completely the work of white hat
researchers you know how always people
say there's got to be one step ahead of
the bad guys right now we're three steps
ahead of the bad guys so that should be
good right so we're
so so why I will talk to you today for
about the cloaker work is a hardware
supported rootkit which will essentially
operates similar to a virtual
machine-based rootkit in the sense that
there's no modifications that are done
to the OS are the applications and the
way it survives by only modifying
hardware state and settings so it
manipulates all these register settings
and hardware flips bits and so on in
order to survive and since there's
absolutely no dependency on any of the
host OS services it has to provide its
own environment for malware and by kind
of essentially divorcing itself from the
rest of the operating system it can
totally evade any signature checkers or
integrity checkers or anomaly checkers
which are only looking at the operating
system so it's some sense such rootkits
essentially exists in a parallel world
from the operating system and that
brings us to hold how do we build such
rootkits so cloaker which I'm going to
talk about today is is built for linux
on the arm platform and like i said it
has to provide its own mini OS
environment essentially for for running
malware and i'm going to talk about a
couple of mallory payloads later on and
the services that cloaker provides our
typical operating system it has memory
management support interrupt management
it has even networking support and
cloaker is a non-persistent rootkit so
since we're talking about a phone here
we we argue that having a persistent
rootkit on the phone i mean a non
person's rootkit on the phone is fine
because people rarely let their phones
died from loss of battery power so
people usually keep it charged but if
you need to go in to persist for
persistence we have to modify some part
of the system and opens up us opens us
up to detection you're the question
said that this will not be detectable by
anomaly detection yes so will it slow
down the execution of the is think of it
as primary OS on the phone anyway it so
the way we've designed our current
rootkit it does slow down the execution
of the primary OS in a little bit and
i'll show you a slide later on that
shows the amount of the slowdown but
there's ways to bypass that as well and
we've discussed that aspect of it and it
boils down to the notion of there are
two things you can do one is actually
how do you measure time and if the time
source is from from a local timer on the
system the rootkit can modify the time
source if it's like an instruction
counter that that can be modified as
well the route you can modify that so
that it can come up with counter
defenses the other thing that we've been
also discussing is since this is a cell
phone system it has to have power
management so we came up with the notion
of essentially running the rootkit just
when the OS is going to sleep so at that
point by definition nothing else should
be running at the system so there should
be no other software monitoring tool
that's going on and the rootkit can
actually run when the system is sleeping
in some sense so there are other
approaches to to countering that problem
and I will talk about that later on as
well another question oh you can have if
you have another question okay with both
of those visitors answers at undone
satisfactory with the first one he said
or maybe is the second running wild
powered down then you're trading off the
battery resource you're consuming more
battery with the first one of a virtual
izing time that takes it that assumes
that you're not dealing with somebody
who can have access to the network as
part of their detection yes and so both
of these
you know saying white saying i'm going
to assume that the that i get to take
the last step in this game rather than
my opponent yeah you're right so the
question I mean the point is it's like a
continual of battle here so if the good
guys come up with a particular solution
the bad guys come up with a counter
solution and that's what you're talking
about here right so the last settle once
I take a look if i get to take the next
step in some sense yes so if you have
the last say in it then maybe and yeah
yes if the person creating the rootkit
has the last say always this that's all
these are you usual case as well because
but in that case I I I don't think
that's that's a worthwhile assumption
because if you make that assumption i
can find out what the code is that is
supposed to be doing the detection and
just make sure it always returns no no
rootkit so right if you set up the game
such that the attacker has the last move
it's active into it what they what the
checkers software is and can just make
sure it modifies the codes
oh but the checker software could also
be protected by a hardware and it may
not be easily modifiable so we are even
talking about scenarios here where the
checker software is is I mean you have a
complete root of trust right from the
hardware to the checker software if the
checker software is only checking the
integrity or signatures in the in the OS
it's still not going to be able to find
our rootkit even and in cases where the
rootkit would modify the OS the checker
software if the root of trust is from
the hardware the checker software cannot
be subverted so you see what I'm saying
if if the checker software has been
authenticated from the hardware and it
cannot be subverted even if the rootkit
were running in in in the OS
yeah so I was talking about arm all this
while and essentially the reason we
looked at arm was because iron powers a
lot of mobile devices today and it's not
just these cell phones and Delta has
like GPS devices and powers the forged
fusion system and so on and there's also
going to be an explosive growth in such
devices yes so by nature offsets I mean
the design of such rootkits is very tied
to the hardware because i'm talking
about hardware features and our
particular rootkit is tied to the arm
platform have you written was simply her
forearm I mean are the things to exploit
the stick to your processor and not say
ah yes almost there could be similar
parallels and other architectures but
certain things that we exploit a very
arm specific what we are trying to do
here is essentially to bring out this
notion of a class of new malware which
is hardware supported and this is just
one instance and I'll show you another
example later on as well but we kind of
trying to bring out this notion of this
existence of this different class so
like I said there's going to be a whole
number of such devices on the market so
there's going to be four billion cell
phone subscriptions in a couple of years
and this is analysts say this and that's
kind of almost one phone for every two
people on the planet and in contrast the
number of PC users is just going to be
like one-fourth of that so it's it's a
platform that has a tremendous impact
and it's not just mobile devices and
cell phones a lot of consumer
electronics toys even use this processor
so the reason I have the slide is that
it shows that the the domain we're
targeting is is significant I think I
probably skipped over slide but what
we're looking at here is essentially a
slide that shows how r rootkit operates
there is actually two things are rootkit
exploits one of which is flipping a bit
that to redirect interrupts and the way
this works is
on the arm platform the arm line there's
two different locations that with the at
which the interrupt vector can recite at
the zero address or at this high address
here and a bit in a processor
configuration register determines where
the interrupts gets get dispatched to
and typical operating systems like Linux
or a couple of other arm based
operations we looked at relocate the
interrupt vector to the high address so
that they can map the slow address to an
owl page and which kind of helps in
debugging so that if there's a null
pointer dereference they can easily
during development they can catch it and
fix it so they always map the zero page
to a novel page and they have the
interrupt vector up there so what
cloaker does is it first flips that bit
the other way so that instead start
getting sent back to the low address and
now the other question is how does
cloaker managed to get get that page
mapped in without modifying the OS page
tables and the way cloaker does that is
it inserts a locked TLB entry and this
is a feature that's on the ARM processor
to answer your question and so it
inserts a locked TLB entry which the OS
has no way to even go and read the arm
doesn't provide support for the OS to go
read these tlb entries even and this
lock TLB and she can essentially map in
arbitrary regions of the physical
address space into virtual memory and so
these addresses are virtual memory
addresses and what happens here is now
that cloaker flips this bit and inserts
a mapping for the zero page it can go
put in an interrupt vector at that zero
page to redirect interrupts to itself
and this essentially brings down to your
question but it's intercepting every
single interrupt now and so what we do
now is we don't want to slow down the
system significantly so what we have
here is for interrupts that are critical
time critical so for timer interrupts we
would just do really quick pass throughs
to the OS we don't interpose on any
timer interrupt path we would only
interpose on interrupts that are very
asynchronous like a network interrupt or
like a keyboard interrupt or something
like that so which essentially gives you
a little bit of protection against a
timing based detection and and when you
run mal recording on a synchronous Pat's
the OS really doesn't know when to
expect those interrupts so it it it
still just delays it'll buy a little bit
yes so you said you inserted til a lot
tlv entry which is what prevents the
system's page table of knowing about the
existence of the memory where it is
running correct the lock tlb entries
essentially avoids modification of the
West page tables right so but then we'll
commence the system from racially
allocating a page in the mini areas
where they would kill is running okay so
that's the next slide I think I'll get
to that in the next slide yes I have a
question just like a you choose to
inject your payload when certain kinds
of interrupter happens like that no work
today sir officers but on the other hand
have you thought about it you just
choose to it injector your interrupter
based on some time are you you keep
themselves about the CPU because for
most interrupts I think they just
execute a critical part with a small
amount of code so it doesn't make a
difference between an hour cap Hackett
arrival or some other thing right the
the critical part is very short then it
just gives up control to the CPU so that
won't make a difference I'm not sure I
understand your question so are you
saying that it's okay to intercept all
interrupts or I'm saying is okayish
balance if you inject you a pillow to
not based on
of the interrupter but based on a pacer
you keep okay a pace that you maintain
so that's definitely possible one thing
that we still are able to do with with
our rootkit is enable any unused timers
for example that are on the on the board
and one of our Palos actually does that
and that would give you a very
controlled pace to do your to do
whatever malware what you want to do so
it depends on how much extra news
functionality is there on the system and
there's one for in our case we're in our
platform the Linux kernel uses two of
the system timers and the third timer
can be used for for malware okay so to
get back to the other question let me
just cover the other part first so how
do we insert this this rootkit we
essentially do use a kernel module for
installation and you could think of
other really stealthy ways of inserting
the rootkit bed directly accessing
physical memory through the dev mem
device on Linux but right now for for
this proof-of-concept we just use a
kernel module where you just do a modern
insert and a module remove and that kind
of inserts the rootkit and to answer the
other question where does physical
memory come from where does the actual
rootkit with side in memory there's
several places to do this one is
essentially to use on ship SRAM so and
these mobile platforms is usually a
couple of kilobytes of on-chip ram that
are that's used for fast executioner for
like power management and you could use
that portion of memory or the other
thing you could use is nor flash nor
flash is I don't know if you know about
this property of nor flash but nor flash
allows you to actually execute code off
of it directly just like you would do
from normal memory so unlike NAND flash
which has to be accessed in blocks nor
flash can you can actually execute code
off of it so you give us memory map nor
flash the other thing you can the
simplest thing we can do is essentially
just allocate some memory inside the
colonel in our module for example and
just cause a memory leak in some sense
so
I mean it just looks like a memory leak
inside the OS so there's several options
we just pick the simplest option use
just came a lock does it answer your
question yes no I mean it's like a
memory leak so you can insert the module
just don't free it okay the next thing
I'm going to talk about is the services
that are provided by cloaker so close
just the hiding mechanism and an
operating environment it has to provide
a couple of services we wrote a service
for diamond dynamic memory management
using the body memory allocation
algorithm eventually we discover that we
could write a lot of payloads without
using dynamic memory management and so
it's an optional kind of payload but
it's still there and we also have
interrupt management supporting cloaker
it would let payloads independently
enable/disable interrupts for different
devices for example they want to monitor
a particular device they can the the the
library also supports look up for the
current interrupt numbers and allows you
to register allows malicious payload to
register handlers first for those
interrupts and it cloak or asus has
networking support and this is not
complete networking support in the sense
that it doesn't have the complete TCP
stack in there it it essentially lets
you do IP communication and the way we
do this in cloaker is we use a really
stripped-down version of the linux
kernel's ethernet driver so the
intuition behind this is you don't
really need code for initializing the
device or tearing down the device a lot
of these different types of
functionality all you need is a routine
that lets you send a packet and routine
that lets you receive a packet and you
can write least you can rebuild this
really small network driver in some
sense and once you have these two
mechanisms to send and receive packets
you can achieve IP networking by
discovering two parameters which are
like the Gateway MAC address and the
source IP address so if you have those
two power
then you can start sending out network
packets and the way we discover those
two parameters is is pretty easy as well
so we intercept a periodically we
intercept some incoming network packets
we pull off a packet from the network
card the oysters not see it but it's
treated like packet loss in the network
so it's treason isn't really a big deal
yes so the reason we didn't want to hook
the vices not modify any part of the OS
so we didn't want to oh you're talking
about actually using the u.s. code
directly yeah so that's definitely
another option that we've also looked at
to just use the code so you don't even
have to have local code in our case we
have to make some modification so that
doesn't interact with the OS driver in
in weird way so the same OS driver the
OS driverless the lips colonel does a
bit of locking and so on which which we
cannot reuse in our rootkit because it
has it modifies OS state why you can't
just put the package says they come out
from the system into like the ikea
hacker and any layer of the stack just
took third redirect
so the only thing we can do is actually
go read a packet if it's an OS buffer we
we can't really modify the OS control
flow in any way because that opens you
up to so if you if you have to modify
control flow then it opens you up to all
those other detection techniques in a
ticket so sir carmine did you describe
my father we need a truck back now Oh
dad zero trust us can you take that
tricks page table I mean issues an issue
I'm prepared to start making education
system so the Alaskan that I mean mean
your eyes really nice mix plus one that
has these three instruction checks
so you're right i mean i mean this one
bit that we flip right and if the West
goes in text for that bit you can you
can necessarily detect our route case
that's what you're saying right in some
sense yes that's definitely true so what
I'm trying to bring out here is is not
that that one particular vulnerability
exists I'm saying that there's a class
of such vulnerabilities and a couple of
slides I'll show you another technique
that doesn't use that flipped with
mechanism and so cloaker is just a proof
of concept the standard mo say that this
class exists and it's not about this
particular vulnerability you can't place
your finger on this thing and say well
this bit is flipped and therefore if I
go check for this I can avoid this class
of rootkits are at this class of malware
so I'll show you what in a couple of
slides another way to do this the
subversion that doesn't use it that bit
so we do get that question a lot so
which is why we had we came up with the
other alternative okay you to route the
moment with open
being that specific it
ah can I interrupt the moment when the
OS is reading that pretty specific bit
so the other attack i'm going to show
you can actually let you do that right
now we can't because we're not
interposing on any OS read operations at
all so we're not modifying we can for we
can possibly insert a TLB entry for
further for that actually the bit
manipulation is essentially a hardware
instruction so it directly leads it off
or processor status register so it's
very difficult to intercept that that
request so unless you're intercepting
that whole page that that instruction
exists on and trying to subvert it it's
more complicated there's an easier way
to do it and I'll show you in a minute
other questions okay so getting back to
the IP networking part so we intercept a
couple of arbitrary packets off the
network we have this packet header
buffer inside inside the insect Locker
which has a prefilled in entries for
first things like the destination MAC
the source MAC and I mean destination
MAC has to be the Gateway Mac and that
needs to be figured out the source MAC
can be read from the from the ethernet
card and it has the IP header fields and
so on and the way we fill fill up this
packet header is that once you see an
intercepted packet that's coming from a
different subnet we just copy the source
MAC off into the destination MAC here
which is actually the gateway Mac and we
copy the destination IP address which is
the source IP address so that we can
source IP address the other alternative
is to go mess with the OS structures but
this kind of gives us a little bit of OS
independence at least and that gives you
complete IP networking yes
and it happening
you cannot attack in other words like
that you set that back to me gateway
which means you can attack any devices
you can only attack once it has yes
you're right so this is just a simple
illustration for how you would
essentially send out information from
the host if you wanted to do some
testing like that you could probably
implement ARP locally as well so it's up
to you how much functionality you want
in the system the other thing I'm going
to spend some time talking about is the
key logger that we have in this in as
built as a payload for for cloaker so
these are a couple of payloads that I'm
going to talk about now and this one
intercepts input on the serial port and
this is like a typical serial port well
considering an NS serial port that's
standard on all pc's as well so they
have similar things on phones and these
serial ports work by having a fifo
buffer for the transmitted and another
favor buffer for the receive the problem
here is now that say you want to
intercept this input that's coming on
the serial port keystrokes the problem
here is that this chip doesn't let you
put back something that you just read so
if you read from the receive fifo it
would essentially shift all the other
content and so it's like a shift
registers and so you read this character
out and there's no way to put this back
in again so this initially kind of led
to some issues and you're figuring out
how to do this key logging with that so
that the OS also still receives that
character so you don't want to read a
character off and the West not receive
it yes so it's for
you want to intercept on the on the
phones there's a specialized a bit of
harder that we haven't really looked I
mean on real phones is specialized bit
of hardware that we haven't really
looked at so this key logger works on
this prototype cell phone board that we
have and on real phones i'm not sure
what the exact us implement hardware is
yeah so what we're doing here is going
to take advantage of a weakness in this
particular chip yeah you're right about
that so we I mean what we're trying to
hear do here is again a proof of concept
as well so we're showing that in this
particular piece of hardware that exists
this this vulnerability and on the on
the prototype hardware that we were
looking at this was the only way to get
a keyboard input into the system version
this particular case you cannot run the
routine
in sleep
yes you're right so so this has to be I
mean you're representing the keyboard in
book which means you delay the input by
a little bit yeah yeah so we didn't have
access to I mean to the real Hardware on
a phone for the keyboard we didn't have
the specs for those that component but
i'm sure there's probably some similar
debug feature in that that can be
exploited so the way we do the serial
port diba I mean exploit is that we
enable this debug feature on this on
this chip which lets you loop back the
transmit lines to the receive lines and
this is used for debugging and we
essentially the way we operate now is we
read all of the input that the user
types in and then set this loop back
feature write it back out and then unset
that feature so that essentially lets
you intercept input and while still
letting that input pass on through to
the OS yes okay so the other possibility
here is to directly find an access OS
buffers and again this requires
understanding the OS internals and while
it's a possibility we just thought this
was more elegant so we wrote another
couple of payloads we wrote
sorry this okay so I understood this so
you're going to beat out with the
pleasure I produce use the loopback sent
back through
so what happens is there's something
coming in oh we're looking at human
input here so the speed at which you can
do the loopback readout and everything
is really fast and so if you can type
you can type two characters in within
microseconds then it's I mean I'm not
trying to essentially say that this
works for a generic serial port
interception at the max yeah that's yes
now this this one in this case we
essentially turn on the debug board
loopback the input and then turn off the
debug mode so this one you wouldn't even
see so the other two Palos that we wrote
we're like a paler that does essentially
a distributed denial of service so it
activates an unused timer like I
mentioned there's some bit of heart with
its unused so whenever it gets a
notification will send out a packet
using the networking support and the
other thing we did was essentially send
out the key log or buffer as soon as
it's full and the problem is I mean as
soon as you have network packets being
sent out now we are vulnerable to
network intrusion detection systems and
we're not going to really delve into
that but I mean especially once you
start doing externally visible changes
you you're opening up yourself to
detection so I'm going to now move on to
the actual evaluation system what we did
so what we the whole thing was designed
and built on the omap h2 platform it's a
Texas Instruments board for the
prototype cell phone essentially and it
has an arm 9 processor core it has i
mean we use the latest linux kernel the
real version doesn't really matter
because
kind of diverse from the OS we can run
with any Linux kernel and the
measurements that we I'm going to talk
about now are like we measure the size
of our rootkit we also look at the
performance impact on the OS to answer
your previous question and i'll also
look at detectability and compare
existing approaches and other rootkits
as well so for the size aspect of it you
can see that we manage the right Locker
in a really compact manner so
essentially this table says that cloaker
is really really small you can actually
have cloaker fit within those couple of
kilobytes of SRAM for example and in our
case we managed to fit all of cloaker
including its payloads within the first
8 kilobytes of memory and the reason for
this is we don't really have to have
that much device driver support and a
palos are simple as well so it's
trade-off if you want more complex
complexity you get larger size but what
we try to show here is that you can get
significant levels of malware
essentially I mean you are still able to
to send out Network packets and is still
able to intercept keystrokes and you
cannot do all of that in a really
compact compact manner then I'll service
in guy people now
so what does that 12 lines of code
so there's really so all it's doing is
she sending a packet over the network
said it it so it's we are assuming a
pre-configured attack target and it's
not there's no control component yet
wide array by better this
okay yeah other 11 lines so this code
that's essentially looking up the
interrupt I mean the timer interrupt
comes in the for the denial of service
payload essentially is the time and
stuff that comes in the interrupt
management system processes it and gives
it to you so there's also code to like
enable that additional functionality
that extra timer reminds there I'm
having a hard time figuring out how you
possibly talk to a nick enough to get
this in a magnet about 10 so the 12
lines doesn't include the actual network
code so so that's included in inside
cloaker so the actual network
interaction the driver some of those 147
yes so this 147 lines of code includes
all the services that cloaca provides so
the networking the interrupt processing
and the memory management we left it out
separately so it's really easy I mean
it's really small because like I said
before you don't have to have all the
code and to answer a question before so
we took out the Linux driver and
stripped out a lot of code from it so we
couldn't reuse the next driver ok so the
performance question so what does this
whole thing due to performance so this
shows a bunch of statistics that are
reported by LM bench and you like you
will notice that there is a small
noticeable change in performance when
you're running cloaker because it's
intercepting interrupts and yes this
definitely does open it up to detection
in some manner and like I was discussing
before it's it's a continual struggle
here yes
so on so you're talking about like
dynamic voltage scaling on the arm that
we're looking at it doesn't have any
dynamic voltage scaling but the other
attack I'll show you in a minute
probably also watch this issue in some
at some at some level so detectability
so what I have here is a big table
there's a lot of information in it but
essentially these this column's lists
all the existing techniques that are
used for rootkit detection so you have
integrity checks of the disc or like the
process platform integrity checks
Colonel integrity checks so I'm
including anomaly detectors for the
kernel inside this this category and the
signature checkers the takeaway from the
slide is the only thing that can
actually go and be able to detect
cloaker effectively is if you do a
complete physical memory scan and search
for the signature yes the amount actors
do the VMM detectors 0 so the VMM
detectors essentially check for the
presence of tlb entries that are being
used up in the system by the VMM so this
was a paper by folks from Stanford and
VMware and they I mean paper was VMM
detection myth or reality and yes
so they have a whole slew of such
methods at the years and TLB sizing and
something they kind of run in order to
see if this tlb entries that are missing
yes so with regards to non persistence
isn't doesn't non-persistent mean that
this process integrity change or
signature offenders should be able to
find that I mean so for user mode you
have user mode not persistence you have
this process solutions yeah so so if you
take a signature of the process you soo
of all processes you'll still find it
right so it's a user mode process so you
can think of this as like a you running
a use of a process and deleting the file
right so it's so it's not on on the disk
I mean if you run it integrity check off
the disk you won't find it I mean a
signature to check out this unless is
checking all disk blocks looking at the
file system it's not there on the file
system anymore because you deleted the
file but you'll still be able to like if
you look at the process itself you have
the process list it's all in usual mode
and a kernel level detector can go
through all the processes and look for
signatures yes explain why the vehicle
detector can detect a vm be ours but not
cloaker because its absence cloaker i
can run poker a run of EMV are as Coco
guerra here right so the reason the
cloaker is not detectable by those VMM
detectors is that at least for this TLB
sizing for example right in in when we
use this those locks tlb entries the
lock tlb entries on the arm are an
exclusive TLB so you're not using up the
the normal tlb entries that are
available for the u.s. so this there's
eight tlb entries that are specifically
reserved for being locked down and those
are not used by the OS and then that can
be used by clover so the OS will still
see no changes in the tlb entries
harmful ways
detector of paper i'm not just talking
about 1 hazard in the detector that
cannot be used to detention right I
think it's right I think people here I
think it's basically what you're saying
is yeah x86 bmm detectors are not
appropriate for caches arm yes right but
but I mean if you retell paper I mean
basically they say is and I think you've
got exact saying prompter you basically
built a vm rootkit I have heart I mean
it's an hour specific vm rootkit instead
of an x86 specific rootkit but it is a
vm brute kid and so the thing is all i
mean i think if you look every single
one of the techniques you talk about are
detectable in the same sense with the
x86 with our it's just there aren't
specifically in your ear up thing your
TLB surely if i was going to write the
paper on how i write a vm detective for
the arm one of the things i would say
well i should flush all I should write
through all of the lock tlb entries
process so you're right so the thing
we're arguing hear about is essentially
so I'm arguing that there's one thing
you can do in order to detect VMM based
rootkits so you can put your finger on
this thing and say I will do a check for
a vm m and there are definite ways to do
that so there's one thing can do and i
can detect all vm m rootkits i think i
think house argument
and how the last paper was it there
isn't one thing that you can do detect
every skip but there are enough things
that it is a cat and mouse game and in
it inevitably you will be able to find
any rootkit that it's in existence you
will be able to find that tells argument
but I mean there's one thing you can
definitely do to in order to detect that
virtualization you are running in a
virtual machine right you can do tlv
sizing there's one thing you can do so
my argument is essentially to say that
there is no one one thing that you can
do in our that will kind of totally
cover the whole class of hardware based
malware so for the VMM rootkits if you
take if you do TLB sizing you can say
that I can detect that I'm running the
virtual machine and that's it so I've
come up with a detection scheme there's
no further question on this on this
topic anymore right I've placed my
finger on that and I'm done clearly not
what this is
but I guess you can discuss this offline
okay yes just to clarify since there are
there are eight of these protection we
have virtual memories tle rejected TLB
spas you can try do a resource
constraint test if you're in the OS to
see whether all aid are available to you
yeah right so I mean so what your
essence is saying is that there has to
be hardware level integrity checks you
have to check the integrity of the
hardware in some sense right the
hardware state and that's what we argue
for as well so I mean we're kind of
saying here that it's not sufficient to
check the integrity and the sanity of
the OS is is you also have to go and
check the integrity of the hardware as
well so you have to consider the system
as a whole both the software and the
hardware parts of it so so we have
argument but checking for the flip bit
right so let me just go ahead and give
you another alternative way of doing
this this control flow subversion that
doesn't use the flip bit technique so
like I said I've been stressing here
individual vulnerabilities aren't the
topic of the stock so I'm not trying to
say that this particular one Lewbert
runner ability exists i'm trying to say
that this class of hardware based matter
that's possible and i'm i'm essentially
arguing that this there's no one thing
that they get place your finger on and
say this is going to detect all hardware
based your keys there's generic
techniques are probably going to be
ineffective so the other technique I'm
going to show you now is using this the
Harvard architecture for the cash so
there's a separate data and instruction
cache and we use a cache line lockdown
support in in the arm in order to do
this this different attack so what we do
is we take a line in the data cache lock
it down and we lock down the correct
values the OS instructions in the data
cache and in the memory we we actually
replace those OS instructions with our
malicious and
structions and once we do this
essentially you have the malicious code
that's getting executed because it goes
to the instruction cache but if the OS
or any detection technique guys do a
checksum or a signature check it will
not see the malicious code because all
of those operations go through the data
cache and let's lock down so again this
is another case where I'm exploiting a
feature of the of the hardware the
architecture in order to hide the
malware yes break this as a checker um
and so I will talk about the mitigation
techniques in a couple of slides okay so
moving on to countermeasures so what we
are essentially saying here is there's
lots of these possible ways you can you
can have hardware essentially enable
malicious software to operate and we
have to have some sort of a way to
completely check the integrity of the
hardware so one way to do this from
software you still need some hardware
support in order to ensure a root of
trust but once you can ensure the
integrity of these checkers you can
build this framework where you have each
driver export a checking function that
checks the integrity of its associated
hardware and this essentially kind of
gives you a way to check integrity of of
various components of the hardware and
the drivers are the right places to put
these checkers because the drivers are
what really understand the hardware so
this is a software based technique the
other things that that are possible are
yes
for the championship
so for example in the driver for the
props processor for example right or it
would essentially have a checker that
checks for the integrity of the state in
the processor and that would check for
the slipped bit for example so I mean
these are these are functions so that
our framework essentially just uses like
return return values in order to signal
or flag that something is wrong so these
are functions that just check some
hardware there's no specific way you
need to write this function as long as
it returns yes or no whether or not the
card where is matches the state which
expects or not should I check her to
check these checkers
yes so so the check management so like I
said before we need to need some sort of
a root of trust from the hardware so
like a TPM kind of system okay yes so I
quickly move on to the other thing as
well so this is the last slide I had on
this thing so you can also do some
hardware based techniques in order to to
to detect such rootkits and the last
couple of notes I had here where if you
have a more sophisticated version you
can also start interpreting OS
structures and do more damage and the
thing about this rootkit is really hard
to write because it interacts with the
architecture of a really low level so it
definitely discourage the script kiddies
so I'm going to move on to the next
section of my talk and I should be able
to finish in half an hour and that's
about the other tool that we did which
compromises systems using forced restart
so the observation here is volatile
memory is not really volatile this Alex
Halderman is going to present a paper at
using security in a couple of months
where he shows or technique to extract
encryption keys from memory after
pulling out the the dims and putting it
another pc and just imaging the memory
and it's not really a new thing as far
back as 1979 people have looked at this
problem and they've shown that you can
actually have this memory persist for a
whole week in fact and the thing here is
you can also revive a complete system
and this is the paper that we some we
wrote it was probably should use nicks
technical conference middle of last year
and we show that we can use this multi
memory preservation property to revive a
system that's been locked up and has
been reset by a watchdog timer and we we
took essentially did it for reliability
reasons but it is much more interesting
to look at it from a security
perspective and what I'm going to show
you in the next couple of slides is kind
of like an illustration of how this
attack would happen so say Alice is
working on her computer she
has a couple of applications opened up
there's banking applications or
essentially some she's opened up secure
connections to various places is a VPN
that's running and so on and she walks
away from a computer temporarily locks
the screen and truly walks in she says
she has briefed access to the computer
and it's a lock stream what does she do
so what sudhi does is no she has she has
boot jacker she forces the computer
restart in some manner I didn't unplug
the part put it back in or are you some
OS support and plugs in bhuj occurs an
alternate boot medium and what boo
checker is able to do is it's able to
revive the complete existing system
that's on that's that was running before
and since it starts up at a lower level
now we can go and switch off any set of
access control mechanism that was in
place so it can disable the screensaver
lock for example so that kind of gives
you the overview of the attack we didn't
really do it for windows like it like I
saw like I show it there we implemented
it only for linux right now and so the
requirements for this whole attack or
you have to have physical access to the
system secrets have to be in memory
there's no point in trying to revive the
system of this there's no encryption key
or this knows there's nothing
interesting in memory and there's have
to be some way of restarting the system
on the linux platform you have a sis r
cube key combination so it's a magic key
sequence again hitting hard immediately
least of the computer you can also power
cycle it and you also have to have an
alternate boot path so you should be
able to boot different from a different
device and you can have that support
either from the bias or if this
bootloader the bootloader could also let
you do booting from a different device
and the memory shouldn't be
significantly clobbered by the bias so
if bias one is booting up goes and
erases all of memory the attack is
worthless and it's it targets the next
based operating systems so let's look at
the assuming with all the other
requirements or ok let's look at the x
ask memory collabera behavior yes
specific sis secure system that is less
secure that was considered to be more
secure than it actually is and that this
research is uncovered that that it is
not that secure is it that when I know I
don't know what I walked my machine I
assume if somebody has physical access
that they can do something yeah just
because I've heard about a USB base
malware yeah but I raising up maybe
maybe there was what is it so say for
example you had you were using I mean
you're aware of all such I mean you are
aware of theft essentially and you rely
on encrypted disks and you rely on VPN
connections tunnels and everything in
order to kind of really protect
information even the face of theft so
you assume in some sense that once i
have an encrypted disk and I've locked
my screen and everything of hibernated
my system and I walked away that if
somebody still steals my laptop they
still won't be able to get to my desk
because when they boot it up back again
it's you need to enter your password
again in order to get to your data so
what I'm showing here is that you can
still get to the to secure data as well
by reviving the whole system so it and
i'm showing here that it's I mean the
problem isn't new like i said before
alex is going to have a demonstration at
sec using security where he has a way of
receiving the keys what I'm showing here
is a way to revive the whole system
there's no need to look for any keys at
all because you can just use the
applications directly so you don't have
a search for anything you can provide
the complete system do you know
hibernate and have encourages
I don't know I think we have one do they
not encrypt memory and for hibernated
systems so some hibernated systems
unless colonel some of them do some of
them don't the newer ones do in this
case we didn't actually even look at
hibernated systems we just looked at a
screen saver lock kind of protection so
as long as it's just sleeping you open
it up there's a screensaver lock and
your keys are still in memory so if
there's aught indication if you walk
away and this it's still requires
authentication already to get your keys
then we won't our system is ineffective
against such architectures yes would it
be sufficient to protect your system to
when the screen is locked to dump the
keys and then have the login
authentication regenerate peace yes so
the attack we're essentially exploiting
here is essentially ability to access
secrets in memory so there's no secrets
in memory it's it's worthless
okay so and I'll just study the bias
behavior but clobbering memory we wrote
a tool that it's on a CD you can boot it
up and you know it'll it'll write a
pattern to memory reboot and then check
if the pattern exists we're and in a
whole bunch of systems and interestingly
dell laptops are totally totally wipe
all of their memory for some reason and
I mean attack is totally ineffective
against any dell laptop and i have a
dell laptop but think paths for all
think about even the newest ones
preserve a lot of memory so this very
little memory that gets erased right
actually this stuff is on her requires
over love it and be part of memory to
get over it I'll freeze by the body ok
that'll does is within all their systems
and so so the memory that I'm talking
about here is only extended memory
everything about one the one megabyte
boundary everything the first 640k of
memory is always used up by the bias
while it's running and totally messes it
up for the Lin axis I mean on the linux
platform the first eight megabytes are
reserved for like is ad is a card DMA so
listen doesn't really use up that memory
and which is why we are able to revive
the system and all the clobbered memory
in the first 640k doesn't matter so
these are a bunch of different laptops
that we'd and a desktop that we tested
this on and so there's two aspects to
this attack right this one first thing
is how do you revive the software part
of it and how do you divide the hardware
part of it because it is a reset and the
hardware also gets reset so the software
resuscitation the goal is essentially to
resume execution of the software
environment and what we do is
essentially come up with a processor
context that we just restore on this on
the cpu which lets lets the system I
mean enable the system to continue
running and for further our attack right
now we assume that we are using the
linux SRQ magic key to reboot the system
it's by default enabled on all bhuntu
based systems and a couple of other
distributions as well so you hit
this our QB and a timidly reboot the
system and what we do here is in the
revival code we go through the stacks
find the stack in which the reboot
handler was called so this is very
operating system specific attack so it
needs to know the layout of the system
and so on and it finds the stack and it
essentially creates a context that makes
it seem like this V boot function
returned without actually rebooting and
we verify that if you do that the system
actually is continues to work and so
while revive reviving the system we had
also find the page tables for the
process that was running and enable
those page tables so that I mean the
system doesn't crash as soon as it's
coming I mean soon as you just show this
complex on the processor so for the
hardware resuscitation we looked at I
mean I'm not going to say that we revive
all the hardware on the system we looked
at some set of hardware and the thing
here to note here is it's sometimes
lynus automatically revive some devices
for you for example the the disk we
didn't really write any code for that
and it's part of the internal recovery
mechanisms of the operating system so
Linux automatically re initializes the
the controller and it revives the disk
so we don't have it waiting for the disk
even the network cards after a little
bit of time out it would do it what we
did we sped it up a little bit by
forcing the timer to occur faster the
display if it's a if it's a linux based
system you can always switch to a text
consult before before running the boot
checker to once it revives it back its
back in the text console and then you
can hit go back to the to the graphic
console and that reinitialize is the
display and the parts that we actually
had to write code for was actually
driving the FPU I mean enabling the FPU
and this is on the x86 and enabling the
interrupt controller system timers and
the keyboards and the mice and this is
essentially very architecture specific
and this is not done automatically by
the US some things we can rely on the OS
to fix some things
we can we wrote a couple of payloads for
this thing as well I mean simple
payloads essentially which kill the
process which we essentially use to kill
the screen saver process and we did
another payload which spawns a root
shell which invokes a shell the shell
command on the system is superuser
privileges and this would essentially
end up being on a virtual console on the
numeric system which is unused and you
can switch to a whole bunch of worship
consoles on alert system by using a
couple of keyboard combinations and to
evaluate a boot jacker wee wee folk for
the correctness test we ran a lot of
applications and interrupted these
applications in between deceive if the
resume execution correctly we did GCC
gzip w get jpeg encoding aes encryption
and all of these applications continue
to run and complete properly after the
reboot the other thing we looked at was
of course since we realize the whole
system we do get access to any program
that's running so we just to prove the
point we ran arbitrarily secure programs
you open up an ssh connection to
somebody else once you reboot the
connection is still open or a web
browser session so if you have a banking
session open you can reboot block is
gone to have the banking session open we
did with VPN connection we also did it
with Linux software based disk
encryption technologies and the key
point to note here and this thing is
essentially unlucky retrieval attacks
which I mean you need to go look for a
particular key or to figure out how to
use it you have to have a completely
different support to do anything useful
to those keys and there's no need to
tailor the attack for a particular key
size or or any such small details so
we've since you drove the whole system
everything is available to us and as for
countermeasures so you think that
securing the boot process may be enough
so if you look at the requirements that
I had before this is requirement for an
alternate boot path
and I would argue that securing the boot
path and or even just doing memory
clearing and the bias doesn't really
help that much because you can do a
memory imaging attack just like what
Alex did so you took out the dims put it
somewhere else and revive the system so
you can always move the memory modest a
different computer ECC is interesting
because we never managed to get ECC
memory to to retain its contents so it
was always reset and that was alex also
riposte the same behavior and hardware
based solution is probably something
that's more appropriate here it's
colleagues at the University of Illinois
was actually Karthik who's actually
going to be here for a for a postdoc
position sometime soon he is working on
this notion of secure core processor
which sseeing has all the secrets so as
long as you make sure there's no secrets
in in volatile memory we can essentially
avoid this attack yes there's a
countermeasure I just how the other
authentication factor be something like
the users password and encrypt all the
memory dinners
oki memory okay so if the I mean if
you're essentially dying your
authentication for the login with the
memory yes that's definitely a
possibility as well work it will work
for specific program specific to this
you debrief you have any civil process
Winnipeg one eyes student but assuming
it's a single user desktop his solution
is definitely so as long as you encrypt
the whole system and it's all tied to
your authentication ID you're fine so
essentially the thing we are expanding
like I said before is as long as the
secrets in memory we can get to it
there's nothing memory if it's all
encrypted we can't get to it so the
hardware that you're taking advantage of
is this interrupt that lets your
research
yeah so the hardware behavior the memory
behavior the remanence behavior so in
the conclusion slide but I have a couple
of slides after this as well and have
time so what I've been showing a talking
to you today about was a couple of
exploits of I guess some off of of a
class of security gaps which exists the
boundary between architecture and system
software and similar attacks can also
exist at other operating systems and
other hardware we haven't looked at it
but there's other people doing work on
this as well it's a recent news article
about somebody looking at the system
management mode on x86 to do something
similar and they've been talking about
the same thing as well that we did with
cloaker where they run a separate
operating system I mean I totally
divorced from the existing operating
system as well and essentially people I
mean system designers should consider
such possible attacks when the designing
secure systems so before I conclude I
just want to talk about a couple of
these briefly overview of some of the
other work that I've been doing my PhD
and so I did a lot of work in US OS
dependability we first looked at how you
use exceptions for error handling we
looked at OS lockup recovery which from
watchdog based research which kind of
led to the boot jack attack so when you
actually poses a security issue it seems
to raise more eyebrows but we did talk
about it at using say DC and the other
thing that we're doing is a building and
operating system that's that's using
Hardware isolated and micro reboot abell
components with state management so when
you're talking about micro rebooting
these components in a microkernel you
have to be careful about the state
that's maintained in each of these
components so if you take a component
that has say for the example the network
stack if you are virtually reboot that
component if if the if there's an error
in that come
what happens is all the existing
applications that are using networking
will fail because all the state is lost
so in our system there's a networking
stack is completely restartable because
all the state for each individual
session is isolated in separate places
in memory in these like green things
here and the states are mapped in and
out on demand using hardware support so
those are a couple of other things that
we've been working on and the idea was
in hot Deb you're hoping to get the
final paper published somewhere else and
as far as future work I've shown you a
bunch of these vulnerabilities I'm sure
there's lots lots of more
vulnerabilities that are possible in
like multi-core architectures a lot of
debug features in these systems I was
reading for example about the SPARC
architecture I this it provides support
for essentially injecting falls and
simulating falls it would take a
processor offline if this many Falls
that happen in the system so if if such
multi-core systems let you for example
offline a core then and if Malheur can
exploit that and actually make the West
thing that is offline the core but
actually runs the Malheur and the other
core it's it's possible attack vector so
there's possible things that we haven't
looked at it in too much detail but it's
something that that's worth looking at
and exploiting hardware virtualization
support and now that you can also do
computations on the other GPUs you can
think of ways that you can probably
maybe have malware running and the GPU
as well I mean not everybody is going to
I mean they're all going to have the
nvidia cards but not everybody is going
to use those nvidia cards for general
purpose computation so this is a wealth
of possible venues here for malware to
exploit and we need to look at defenses
for such attacks come up with hardware
software solutions mostly it has to be
collaborative solution mostly
the other thing that I've been tying
with and I tying with us essentially to
come up with a way to evade intrusion
detection systems that are running on a
computer by having userspace process
directly interact with the hardware by
so if its memory man memory-mapped
hardware he'd still use these TLB tricks
that I was talking to you about in order
to give a user space process direct
access to hardware and by not using the
AOS API which is where the monitoring is
done for typical intrusion detection
systems that could give you a little bit
more stealth in some sense and that's
another idea I've been toying with and I
guess I'm pretty close to the end of the
time so i can take more questions no
questions ok ok thank you very much